这个男孩他内心有很多积压的一些委屈，
一些问题，
他自己是解决不了的，
他没有办法用很好的沟通啊，
语言啊，
用这种拥抱啊，
用疏解去他心里的那些委屈和伤害，
这个事情可能也不能怨他，
也不能怪他，
但确实他是一个信号，
你跟一个他自己内心有很多东西没有解决，
很多扣没有解开的人生活在一起，
对于你来说的话，
可能是你无法承受之重，
无法承受的这样一个风险。
第一个是关于我弟弟的问题，
第二个的话是我感情方面的问题，
我想来姐姐给我多一点点时间好的，
没问题，
大家的耐心听讲。
首先是第一个，
我今天是回到家里面，
是无意中看到我自己的日记，
我发现他对特别内耗，
甚至他也写到有场精春的念头，
我的家庭是比较破碎的，
我家里有几个成年都是有精神方面的问题，
然后我妈妈体定那种智力低下的，
会这一点，
就小时候就经常被邻居欺负，
也是被我爸这边他那些所谓的亲戚就嘲笑，
被他他们看不起。
第二个就是我大姐小的时候被霸凌吧，
她就是得了精神分裂症，
治疗了3年左右，
她现在就是每经化吃药，
已经有两年都没有复发了，
已经定下来了。
还有一个就是我的二姐，
她是得了双向情感障碍，
被这个疾病折磨了8年左右，
她在4年前。
选择结束了退伍，
我弟弟今年是17岁，
我高三了，
他本来也是一个很活泼开朗的孩子，
自从经历了我姐姐的离世，
明显的感觉到他变了，
去到中之后就感觉他变得是比较自卑，
跟他讲话都能感受，
但是她的眼神辛苦避的这段时间也是见我所能的，
就对他好一点，
我会给他买很多鼻子鞋子什么的，
我也会给他转一些生活费什么的。
之前他读高一的时候，
我就有问他是不是在学校有人欺负他什么的，
然后他就明确的表示没有，
我就跟他说，
我要是有什么不开心的事情你就跟我讲，
他对我还是有一定的距离感，
在我面前他就装的什么事都没有，
也不会跟我讲任何事情。
我弟弟他也是有很多优点的，
他就是学一些读课理理，
学滑板啊，
学剪辑，
这些他都学的特别快，
他也很爱干净，
他的房间他都会整理的很整洁，
包括他也很乐意干，
以往他觉得是一件很自律的事情，
但是呢，
我爸就看不到他任何优点，
经常就是指责他，
说他读书读不好，
他成绩越来越差了，
我也经常批评他，
我跟我爸沟通，
我就能明显的感觉到我爸特别生气，
他说他很心痛，
我说这个事情要顺其自然，
但是他都听不进去，
还会道德绑架我们，
我现在就放弃跟他沟通了，
沟通的过程都非常的自信，
解决不了任何问题，
我想问一下，
我应该怎么做，
我才能帮到我弟弟，
你现在是个什么情况，
你跟我说一下，
我现在是暂时没有工作，
刚辞职，
我。
的工作里，
大概可以赚8000~1万一左右，
我现在是回家了，
那你手上有存款吗？
暂时没有，
因为家里的事情，
我欠了很多钱，
才刚还完这些贷款。
如果你想要帮到你弟弟的话，
可能就是得出去找一份工作，
就是你的收入不光是能自己吃喝用，
还有一部分是可以支持你弟弟，
这样你弟弟就不会受你爸爸的管控，
不会受你爸爸的控制。
你给你弟弟托个底，
你说姐姐管你，
姐姐能养的活你如果说在经济上，
你要是能给弟弟提供一个兜底的话，
或许能够等弟弟再大一点了，
他自己也能打工了，
离开那个精神压榨、
精神打击、
精神迫害的爸爸，
对他来说可能是个好事儿，
在外租个房子，
离爸爸远一点，
也要给他宽宽心，
也未必说是要考上了大学才是一定有出路的，
经常跟他看一下，
我说成绩不重要的，
我让他就是放宽心，
就算读不到好的大学，
我可以带他出来学别的，
他跟其他自己有天赋，
我可以带他出来学我，
但是我就发现他8月3号的文日记忆都提到，
他说他的脑子应该跟他的身体是一体的，
他说如果我脑子想法好了，
那我的身体也会好，
身体好了那我想法也会好，
是不是家庭的关系让他好像很成熟，
如果我是你的话，
我可能会换一个角度跟我弟弟说，
我可能说。
姐姐在这个世界上，
爸爸也依靠不住，
那姐姐将来还得依靠你，
姐姐还需要你保护姐姐，
以后如果说嫁了人了，
还需要你给我撑腰，
或许这是一个能够留住她的一个念想，
就是他活在这个世界上，
他还得保护姐姐呢，
还得给姐姐撑腰呢，
他还得以后强大了之后，
嗯，
能给姐姐长脸呢，
不然以后姐姐被谁欺负了，
都没有人给姐姐撑腰呢，
你从这个角度去多跟他聊，
就是你需要他，
你需要他保护你，
需要他给你撑腰。
另一方面就是你现在可以给他撑腰，
因为你能挣八千一万，
你很优秀了，
你将来如果说爸爸不给他读书，
爸爸不给他钱，
可以帮衬他的，
说别的事情的话，
就是你自己也得多顾着点自己哈，
但是人性很好，
看了四五年了，
我今年已经还完，
我有很大的进步了，
我打算是可惜过后就去找工作的，
我要存钱了，
你说你朋有啥问题？
我还有一个感情的问题是跟我男朋友，
我男朋友是03年的，
也是99年的，
她的家庭也是很不好，
她之前是跟着她爸爸一起工作，
她爸爸也是老是打压她，
也是她顶流嘴巴拉着我的面，
我爸爸就打他了，
我男朋友就扇嘴巴掌，
之前是没有发现这个问题的，
是前两个月他就一边打自己一边说我该打他，
就这样说，
我那时候都吓坏了，
后面我跟我男朋友沟通，
从他口。
跟我得他爸爸以前打过他妈妈，
他爸爸还从此去过好几次了，
导知他爸妈离婚了，
本来本来就说他以后绝对不会成为那样的人，
后来有一次我跟我男朋友吵架了，
但那一次还是打了自己巴掌，
我的问题也很大，
我跟那时候也是因为一点小事就他大吼大叫的，
然后凶他，
所以导致他很委屈，
然后就打了自己巴掌，
我们两个就发现了彼此的问题，
我们也想的以后要越来越好，
要改变自己的问题，
我在想这件事情要不要原谅他，
因为我知道就是像这样的男生，
他是以后有点暴力倾向爱了，
我就一直在纠结我要不要原谅他，
而且我们两个不打算结婚，
也不打算生小孩，
而且一直谈恋爱，
就是他这种情况，
我可不可以再给他一次机会，
然后也给我这么一次机会，
姑娘，
如果说你自己假设你自己非常坚定是丁课，
你可以再观察一段时间，
但是呢，
从我的这个角度来说的话，
因为本身你现在并不是一个内心特别强大的，
特别有能量的这样一个女性，
所以你面对她的这种家庭环境，
她从小长大的这个经历，
她的脆弱，
她的伤害，
你可能很难有这样的力量去抚平那些创伤，
抚平他心里从小长大被他爸爸打和他爸爸出的这些伤痛，
我感觉这个事情呢，
是你可以观察一段时间，
但凡你感觉到他确实有不理倾向，
他确实没有办法控制自。
的情绪和行为，
哪怕你觉得他是爱你的，
但他不具备怎么去爱你的这个能力，
不知道怎么去爱你，
那你也要离开他，
因为你自己就已经是泥菩萨过江，
自身难保的状态了，
你已经没有多余的力量去帮助另一个人修复他的童年创伤，
帮助另一个人走出他的阴霾，
帮助另一个人解脱他的原生关系。
他也是有很多优点的，
他知道我的家庭，
这样知道我的经历，
他就一直负责了我的所有的生活的开销，
我的工资钱还我的贷款，
他对我也很好，
就上次他爸爸打了他嘛，
我反着嘛，
他就很感谢我，
还给我转了2000块钱，
他生日的时候我给他买了礼物，
他又把他的工资转给我。
就是他也有很多优点，
家务活也会做，
只是有时候比较懒，
其实我照样去做，
我就想着他的优点跟这些缺点，
还是在观察一段时间，
如果他下次还把自己的话，
我就坚决的跟他分开，
是吗？
是的，
因为他打自己这个行为啊，
他是一个信号，
这个信号是什么呢？
就是这个男孩他内心有很多积压的一些委屈，
一些问题，
他自己是解决不了的，
他没有办法用很好的沟通啊，
语言啊，
用这种拥抱啊，
用疏解去他心里的那些委屈和伤害，
这个事情可能也不能怨他，
也不能怪他，
但确实他是一。
一个信号，
你跟一个他自己内心有很多东西没有解决，
很多扣没有解开的人生活在一起，
对于你来说的话，
可能是你无法承受之重，
无法承受的这样一个风险很好，
我知道如果有一天咱们要分开的话，
咱们要留活扣，
这个活扣是什么呢？
就是我经济条件好一点，
你呃给我付出的这些钱，
我到时候会还给你，
要留这个活扣，
不要让人觉得好像跟你谈了一场恋爱，
好像后鸡飞蛋打，
人财两空似的，
人家说到哪考完就把钱都转给他了，
但是他都没有收，
然他把钱转给他爸，
因为他爸其实也给了我挺多钱的，
就是他给我的钱我都转给他们了，
但是他们都没有收，
反正就如果有一天要分开了，
咱要留活口，
对你吧，
我为什么要说这个问题呢？
是因为我觉得他的爸爸能当着未来儿媳妇的面去打自己的儿子，
这是一个非常强的信号。
正常的父亲如果在还没过门的儿媳妇儿面前都忍不住，
那我觉得他不是一个正常的父亲。
你想想这个男孩儿，
他从小长大的过程当中，
他经历了多少内心的创伤，
经历了多少伤痛，
那这些伤痛，
如果你作为一个女性，
你没有强大到那种可以去抚平她，
重新养育她，
重新把它再养一遍的这种程度的话，
那很难记得。
点赞关注哦。